oh [ __ ] you are kidding me
I cannot believe that Rhonda has set the
alarms off fighting some of my favorite
friends it's my kitchen to make an
amazing scrambled egg and today trust me
I am super excited super [ __ ] myself
because she is Olympic medalists one of
the most prolific UFC fighters she's now
a WWE star and guess what she's turned
into a chef because she's raising her
own cattle and she's bought some of that
ingredient here and there's one thing
for sure that I am not letting her near
my [ __ ] arm
Rhonda welcome I can come down a little
I mean I know I've had presents before
like knives and blaster no one's
actually ever bought me beef and eggs
this is your beef your eggs yes this is
from Kobe he's wagging steer our first
one we ever raised amazing and he's
created a 3 plus we loved him and brush
them and everything fed them ourselves
every day and he's very very special to
us so I wanted to share him with you and
these eggs are from our ladies Mary Jane
Ethel and fired duck first of all
congratulations first-ever double
champion not just in the UFC buck that
we do as well right thank you yeah
straight for us UFCW in a little but I
mean you look at that resume you only 33
years of age I've got three daughters
they've all been big fans since the age
of 9 10 and now they wanna wrestle they
started you did sue and they trained and
they just want to be the next Rhonda
Jeff any idea the impact you've had on
that female sort of upbringing I'm aware
that my daughter's gonna have to do a
less [ __ ] than me and my mom did a
lot of work to make sure that were the
last [ __ ] than her and so your
daughters are next in the relay now we
will do an amazing breakfast burrito
yeah you ready yeah yeah great I 5 men
will cut you into farming zombies right
I saw 28 days later yes start having
reoccurring zombie dreams right and then
I met my husband who's really big into
survival and stuff I thought I should be
doing something right yes person who
further
what am i doing we're gonna put the beef
off first okay so you can follow me all
right okay and we're gonna get that beef
sort of almost sort of colors as Kobe so
there's no fat in there you don't spray
anything it's really so much faster
right on it that's the idea
sure yo yeah so when they hit that in
the pan break it up break it up exactly
that yeah and you'll see it sort of
crumble so this beef was reared for how
long it was two years old when we
harvested um we race them for a year
ourselves gotcha
so no but a little bit of seasoning
pepper so when that's hot there like
that just wow so yeah just in case don't
die so fast
yeah good go so the idea of the farm
life that's the way that you get away
from everything and can you relax on
there I think it's just in like a world
where you get a lot of outside
validation you need to find work that's
like validating yes you know so every
time I go back there and like hang out
with animals yep I'm just making their
day better like every time I go back
there and do something makes them a
little bit happier and I like the most
immediately
dating activity never done oh [ __ ]
you're kidding me
I cannot believe that Rhonda has set the
alarms off oh my god open the window
guys [ __ ] damn it we just started it's
like a round one yet damn right tea
break everybody happy right no bigger
the guys so take you no knife no okay
but I mean where your thumb is there and
look just put your thumb there and just
turn that around and that just takes out
that little sort of core and then we're
gonna slice that cut that down now do
you miss walking inside that object now
you don't know no I uh
I miss training a lot I miss hitting
mitts I miss like going to the gym like
every day and just I don't know like the
little things yep
so we're gonna slice that up and then
cut that into a little dice so we can
start this sort of little salsa for this
incredible breakfast burrito
straightened and then a nice tablespoon
of olive oil and then roll that lime
roll it like that you're lying boil
yeah no table available that's it I'll
show you cuz we roll it like this when
we come to squeeze it you know liters
all wet juice so much easier beef is
resting bigger the guy's done its come
with eggs so gonna make scrambled eggs
but with eggs how about I told you like
don't put the paper towel down it's no
[Applause]
absolutely
oh god you're smart see that is not
going to waste you have a train
whichever's I try to let grapple around
them but it just turns into a giggle fit
because I'll do something like super
witty like haha he'll never know how to
get out of this and then he'll just pull
something out of his ass and like it
just I don't know he's just so smart it
like makes me laugh and then we just
ended up giggling the whole time when
he's on the verge of that arguments who
wins truthfully I don't crush him did he
go down on one knee to propose was he
romantic because I can't imagine him
being romantic oh my god you want to
know how it happened we were actually we
were hunting in New Zealand because
we're very big into sustainable meat he
shot this one thar it was across this
ravine hit um kill shot fell into ravine
and like down in a river and then
proposed to you no not yet cuz rain the
day before we're like oh my god ghosts
gonna get washed away so we like run
down the mountain as fast as we can to
get there and the goat is at the bottom
of a waterfall but the arrows sticking
like straight up in this most beautiful
thing I ever saw you put the ring one
into the boat
what we put the ring them into the boat
now you're almost there I'm sleeping in
the eyeball so we're dog almost there so
so he was trying to clean being like cuz
I hate smiling and he was just like hey
babe I know it's you know over a dead
animal but you know it was Zealand when
her waterfall were you Amy should I was
like what no champagne no she loves me
but he totally didn't say I love you he
was just totally like itemized list he
was like dead animal New Zealand
waterfall marriage studios did you say
yes I said yes before he even for even
he pulled it out and I was like haha let
me say so yeah we got engaged over dead
animals right it scrambled eggs
Duncan trembled egg that I got the Kobe
fat as well put a little bit button
there so sort of super firm Masha
there you go
yeah and then and that's fine in there
and then you know vaginas don't have
what they are they little stunt vaginas
Nazi bastard seriously yeah like wait
ones like they have like but where's it
hidden in like say like a couple
different like vaginas I have no idea
that Ducks have fake vaginas ducks are
crazy man they're descended from
dinosaurs Jesus Christ take off the heat
but it'll touch the creme fraiche in
there and that's gonna cool it down that
stops the eggs from becoming sort of
runny obviously and then back again yeah
put the pan on there now this is good
they're doing well girl oh by the way
congratulations the cookie series by the
way oh my god what kind of things you're
cooking my first episode I cook baked
hot wings because I'm obsessed with
buffalo wings but I'm also an athlete
and so it's like a way that you can kind
of like hopefully bake them but I like
well let me tell you what my show Gordon
Ramsay really so take your chili powder
and just lightly season your eggs from
the chili powder and a little touch of
cumin as well just a touch okay and let
that sort of sit in there and then
tortillas in get them nice and crispy
like that that flavor especially that
butter in there really really nice so
yes okay right crispy tortillas done
crispy should put this together yeah so
scrambled egg on first okay and be
Jennifer discovered a keg stuck eggs
take this gorgeous Kobe
sit down on top avvocato on men from
their little touch of my pika the guy
touching there not too wet just a little
bit in the middle now for the exciting
part under my homemade you can do open
my homemade this I just don't know
letting it be a mess I told me kids if
it's if you didn't make a mess of one
there good beautiful
scrambled tortilla breakfast yeah well
done Joe
so you have a taste of mine all right
hey this is Jill buck from Fox Sports
called Super Bowls world series now I
get to call armwrestling it's not
Stallone in over the top this is Gordon
Ramsay and rounder Rousey who I would
put money on any day and this thing just
seems like it was organic it just
exploded out of nowhere and now here
they are going lefty and Gordon looks
like he's done this before here we go
a kiss on the hand and now I don't I
don't even know I'm pull dirt or them
now it's like a fireman's carry and
there's a lot of tension here between
Ronda and work now there's a Heimlich
thing going which
not good your chef should know that move
Ronda is calling for help and now wham
down he would have gone Gordon may have
won the arm wrestling folks but I think
Rhonda would have taken him down and
that might have been the end of Gordon
Ramsay thank you so much
medic holy [ __ ]
poor Travis oh [ __ ] listed one more
clean don't are getting bad luck I'll
get that duck with a ticket for JJ let's
go